والى فرنسا وفي اطار العواجل التي
شاهدناها على الشاشه المجلس الدستوري
الفرنسي صادق على قانون رفع سن التقاعد
المثير للجدل مراسل العربيه افاد بان
المجلس صدق على البنود الاساسيه للقانون
وفي هذه الاثناء تعهدت النقابات الفرنسيه
باستمرار الاحتجاجات حتى الغاء هذا
القانون وكانت المظاهرات اليوم قد تجددت
لاسيما بالعاصمه باريس وشهدت التظاهرات
اشتباكات بين المحتجين وقوات الشرطه رفضا
لرفع سن التقاعد
اذا مشاهدينا المظاهرات لا زالت مستمره في
فرنسا رفضا لهذا القانون الذي اصر عليه
الرئيس الفرنسي وها هو المجلس الدستوري
يصادق عليه يصادق على القانون كان هناك
حديث عن خيارات مختلفه منها رفض القانون
او تعديل جزئيا او قبول كاملا وقد تم
المصادقه تمت المصادقه على القانون بشكل
كامل كما ان المجلس الدستوري الفرنسي رفض
تنظيم استفتاء لاقرار اصلاحات على نظام
التقاعد على هذا القانون المثير للجدل
الذي اخرج الفرنسيين الى الشوارع خلال
الفتره الماضيه نتحدث مشاهدينا عن اسابيع
مختلفه خرج فيها المتظاهرون واشتبكوا ايضا
مع الشرطه نستمع
[موسيقى]
اذا وفي اول ردود الفعل مشاهدينا كما
نشاهد على العواجه الان اليسار الفرنسي
يتعهد باستمرار القتال بين قوسين طبعا
القتال الخروج في مظاهرات المطالبه
باضرابات وغيره ضد قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي تم تاييده من قبل الحكومه
والان المجلس الدستوري يصادق على قانون
رفع سن التقاعد وايضا يرفض كليا فكره
الاستفتاء تنظيم استفتاء لاقرار اصلاحات
على نظام التقاعد طلب بها الفرنسيون
وخرجوا الى الشوارع في الفتره الماضيه
مظاهرات قويه وحاشده كانت في الشوارع
الفرنسيه ومواجهه واشتباكات ومناورات مع
الشرطه الفرنسيه بين الفتره والاخرى ولا
زالت المظاهرات مستمره على كل المزيد
ولنقل الصوره معنا من باريس مدير مكتب
العربي حسين قنيبر اهلا بك حسين ردود
الفعل الشارع تفضل
نعم كما تشاهدين خلفي ميسون اعداد كبيره
من المتظاهرين تتجمع هنا امام مقر بلديه
باريس للتعبير عن خيبتها من قرار المجلس
الدستوري الذي اعتبر البند الرئيسي في
مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد وهو البند
الذي يتعلق برفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما
الى 64 عاما يعتبروا ان هذا البنت تحديدا
الذي اثار عاصفه من الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
منذ منتصف شهر يناير كانون الثاني الماضي
هذا البند موافق للدستور اي ان المجلس
الدستوري لم يرفض البند الذي يرفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما هو رفض
بنودا اخرى غير رئيسيه سيصار الى تعديلها
لاحقا ولكن الاساس في مشروع القانون اعتبر
المجلس الدستوري انه ليس مخالفا للدستور
وبالتالي فانه يفترض ان تقوم الحكومه بسن
هذا القانون خلال 48 ساعه ميسون بعض
البنود الاخرى لا يعني الشارع ولن يهدئ من
غضب وخيبه امل الشارع
على الاطلاق لان البند الرئيسي الذي كان
الشارع يعول على ان المجلس الدستوري لن
يعتبره موافقا للدستور اعتبر المجلس انه
موافق للدستور اي ذلك المتعلق برفع سن
التقاعد الى اربعه وستين عاما اليمين
واليسار اجتمع على انتقاد قرار المجلس
الدستوري تحديدا اقصى اليمين بزعامه
تمارين لوبان اعتبر ان مصير مشروع قانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد لم يحسم بعد وبالتالي
فان ما صدر عن المجلس الدستوري ليس حكما
نهائيا طبعا براي مارين لوبان زعيمه اقصى
اليمين فيما اعتبر اقصى اليسار لزعامه جون
لوك ان المجلس الدستوري اثبت من خلال
موافقته على البندر الرئيسي في مشروع
اصلاح قانون نظام التقاعد اثبت المجلس
الدستوري حسب ميلانشون انه يهتم بحاجات
الملكيه الرئاسيه كما يسمم العشرون حكم
ماكرون يهتم المجلس الدستوري بحاجات
الملكيه الرئاسيه اكثر من اهتمامه بحاجات
الشعب السيد لنفسه قال من ابسط اليسار
ميسون ماذا بعد هذه الموافقه او المصادقه
من قبل المجلس الدستوري خطوات الرسميه في
اي طريق يجب ان يذهب هذا القانون
وبالمقابل ما هي الخيارات المطروحه امام
الشارع ان كان اليمين اقصى اليمين او
اليسار
[موسيقى]
في الشق الاول بالنسبه للشق الاول من
سؤالك الطريق الذي سيسلكه مشروع القانون
هو طريق ان تعمد الحكومه الى السن القانون
خلال الساعات الثماني والاربعين المقبله
على مستوى الاعتراض الشعبي والحزبي يفترض
ان يجتمع تحالف النقابات الرئيسيه الثماني
اللي يقرر المقبل من التحركات الشعبيه حتى
الان نظم 12 يوما من التحركات الاحتجاجيه
النقابيه والشعبيه منذ منتصف شهر كانون
الثاني يناير الماضي كان اخر هذه
الاحتجاجات ذلك الذي نفذ امس وجمع في
الشارع مليون ونصف المليون بحسب النقابات
و380,000ا من المتظاهرين بحسب وزاره
الداخليه التحرك المقبل سيقرره تحالف
النقابات الرئيسيه الثمانيه في كل الاحوال
هذا القرار للمجلس الدستوري نستطيع القول
انه اشعل الشارع الفرنسي مجددا
الرئيسيه اليسار بتصريحاته قال بانه
سيستمر في عمليه القتال بين قوسين القتال
على مستوى التحرك في الشارع او في خيارات
اخرى بالنسبه له
طبعا يقصدون على مستوى التحرك في الشارع
اخرى يمكن للمعترضين يمكن للمعترضين من
احزاب ونقبات ان يلجاوا الى مجلس الدوله
الذي يمكنه وخلافا لما قرره المجلس
الدستوري يمكنه اي مجلس الدوله ان يعترض
على المراسيم التطبيقيه لمشروع قانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد لا يمكن لمجلس الدوله
ان يعترض على ما قرره المجلس الدستوري
لناحيه موافقه مشروع اصلاح قانون التقاعد
لبنود الدستور ولكن يمكن لمجلس الدوله ان
يعترض فقط
ان يعترض على المراسيم التطبيقيه للقانون
ولكن من حيث المبدا الاساس في مشروع اصلاح
النظام التقاعدي قد وافق عليه المجلس
الدستوري وهو ما سيشعل الشارع الفرنسي
مجددا وعلى نطاق واسع ميسون من باريس مدير
مكتب العربيه حسين قنيبر شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات